Donald Trump has announced a new policy for
the Corona virus bailouts.
That is exactly the type of so-called socialism.
Note that I use the word so-called that he
promised us multiple times now that this country
would never, ever, ever do.
Trump announced it via Twitter, of course,
saying that, quote, Starting early next week
at my order, the United States will be purchasing
from our farmers, ranchers and specialty crop
growers.
Three billion dollars worth of dairy, meat
and produce for food lines and kitchens.
Farmers to family, food box.
Great news for all.
There are so many things here to talk about
and to deal with.
So first of all, yeah, if you have not heard
about this, that we have food lines here in
the United States and they're growing and
they're huge.
All right.
The number of people lining up at food banks
waiting hours outdoors in the heat, waiting
to get food.
And also at certain non-profits and other
organizations that are doing these food boxes
either for free or heavily discounted.
This is what people like Trump often say.
You would only see in socialist or communist
countries.
But it's happening here.
It's happening here in the United States.
It's been happening, but it's happening even
more acutely because of Corona virus.
That's number one.
These are the bread lines that Don Junior
and others decried and announced.
We would never have this in the United States.
Just months ago, they said it.
It's here.
It's been here, but now it's here even more
strongly.
Number two, one could argue that this is even
more than just a socialist idea.
Trump is coming up with I'm not going to call
it communist, but certainly we could be talking
about state socialism.
The government will become the buyer from
people who who raise food manufacturer, raise
grow food.
They are going to be the buyer, the government,
and they are going to be doing that to keep
the company afloat.
And they are going to redistribute those resources
to people who cannot afford them or who don't
have food to eat.
Now, remember, Trump has said many times we're
never going to be a socialist country.
Here's one example from the United Nations.
Today, I repeat a message for the world that
I have delivered at home.
America will never be a socialist country.
In the last century, socialism and communism
killed 100 million people.
Now, of course, I want to be really clear.
I'm not telling you that this policy is necessarily
a bad idea given where we are today.
Obviously, preventing it would have been much
smarter.
I am not here to tell you that we are now
a socialist country.
I am also not a socialist.
What I am telling you is that this alpha pull
yourself up by your bootstraps ideology very
quickly changes when things get tough.
And this is exactly the critique of capitalism
that a social Democrat like me has been making
for years.
We had been listen.
Of course.
Inequality has been huge.
Wages have been relatively stagnant for decades
by a whole bunch of measures.
Two months ago, we had a solid economy again
by the measures that are typically used.
We can argue whether it's thanks to Trump
or not.
I think mostly it's not thanks to Trump.
But we had low unemployment.
We had a high stock market.
We had appropriate inflation rate.
We had high consumer confidence.
Wages were ticking up despite not not being
anything too dramatic.
Yes, of course, too much poverty.
We had hunger, inequality.
I get it.
But compared to lots of times past and many
other countries, things we're doing OK.
Two months ago.
So the lesson is look at how quickly we now
have 15 percent unemployment potentially going
to 20 percent.
And how quickly we have explosive food lines
that are hours long and how quickly we have
the government buying food from farmers to
redistribute to people who can't afford it.
This is not about we should be a socialist
country.
It's just a reminder that the U.S. has had
socialism when it's convenient for a long
time, when there are calamities, when you
need to bail out an industry with companies
that are too big to fail while you'll apply
socialism, there need to spread the costs
out of fixing the environmental damage done
by industry.
Socialized the.
Cleanup, capitalism for the profits, socialism
for the cost.
If you have a virus that you mishandled leading
to an even worse economic implosion than we
would otherwise have had.
Well, just start buying food and giving it
to people in food lines.
So the solution here is we should be dealing
with the fragility of the system in a proactive
way instead of reacting in what is a completely
impotent way.
That is the problem.
And the point of social democracy is you take
capitalism, but you commit money to proactively
insulating the system from shocks and calamities.
Free market capitalism, by its nature, doesn't
do proactive.
It does.
It's just not in there.
It's too expensive.
It's not immediately beneficial.
True free market capitalism would not do the
proactive stuff.
That's why you need the regulatory framework
of social democracy.
And again, this isn't the type of stuff Trump
said we would never have here.
And he's doing it and he's right to do it.
I want to be clear.
It's the right.
It's one of the right policies given what's
going on.
The logistical and crony istick elements of
it will, of course, be a disaster, as it always
is the case for Trump.
But the point is their principles evaporate
when they have a situation like this to deal
with.